what do you think about
edward snowden living in russia and
being protected by russia
and we're snowden
because he's obviously they know he's
xcia or was he nsa
he was in it he was an nsa contractor i
have very strong feelings about snowden
because so
so i am a fan of whistleblowers right
like
something if something is like like the
government
can do wrong things people in the
government
can because right the government is made
up of people so
people can be corrupt people can be
shady so
of course it's possible that something
that should not be happening
is happening right like something that
doesn't have enough oversight
right like so whistleblowers great like
let's keep things in check
i do not see snowden as a whistleblower
i he he
i had other names for him that i will
not use but
you can use him i he
he divulged um like class
like classified information for for what
i consider to be no good reason
if there was something going on that
should not have been going on there is
number one
a chain of command to follow to report
it
you do not just release classified
information
to the world and the fact that he went
to like i think he ran to cuba first and
then to russia
like our actual enemies right like
what are you going to hong kong or hong
kong chinese i mean
anyways like so hot right so hong kong
russia not friends right so i feel very
strongly that
maybe he thought he was doing the right
thing my guess is he had a very good
handler
who convinced him because that's how it
works especially with those types of
countries right he had a good handler
who convinced him he was doing the right
thing for his country
he was not doing the right thing for his
country and for me i was really affected
because that data
that he like that data and those
programs that he released
like targeters use those like i
like like anybody who thinks that their
information is private what do you mean
targeters so targeters use data right
like that's what i do that's my job
like or was so targeters use
all kinds of data it's like being a
private investigator like on
crack like because you have access to
tons more
data um just because of
the government has access to data um so
it's like how like if a private
investigator goes online and they can
see your facebook page and your
instagram and they can there's
certain things that they can find out
about you right like imagine that
like exponential right
but that data comes from somewhere so
like
the apple and google will share it um
you know i just with the government
right with the government
for a purpose right like without that
it is very difficult like that
information
helps us find terrorists that
information helps us stop terrorist
attacks
that information helps us find
intelligence officers
in our country and overseas who are
trying to do our country harm
right like that information is not
telling me
that you are cheating on your wife like
if you think that like
i have huge issues with people and
privacy
because like if you are if you are
online
anything digital if you have a phone or
you are online
there is no privacy for you i i hate to
tell you
like i don't care what agreement you
sign or whatever
it exists somebody can hack it
somebody's collecting it
it's being used whether it's being used
by the government to
stop terrorists or to collect
intelligence for our country or whether
it's being used by
marketers to advertise to you it's being
used it's not private
so when the snowden thing happened
and and a number of people started
chiming up and being like oh my gosh
look what the government's doing and
they're spying on us
we are not spying on you i'm you know
if the cia first of all cannot spy on an
american
they have to have permission to touch
anything american related
like u.s sit related the fbi
can that's their purview right like they
are responsible
if the fbi is watching you you're
probably doing something wrong
if you're doing something wrong and
you're worried about your privacy you
should probably stop doing something
wrong
like right if you're selling drugs and
you're worried that your privacy is
being invaded
you should probably stop selling drugs
like you're doing something wrong
um yeah so it's and and the cia is not
looking at you
i promise you unless you are an
undercover like
chinese intelligence officer nobody's
looking at your stuff
nobody's listening to your phone calls i
promise right well what wasn't
his his overall reasoning for doing this
was because of
the so-called patriot act that was
enacted after 9 11
was used and it was actually proven that
they
were taking transcripts and actually
recording
and actively listening into like
millions of americans phone calls
whether they had any sort of any sort of
reason to do it or not right so
think about like the easiest way to
gather data
right so like you have you have a giant
bowl of m
ms here right and i need to get like the
green m m
that's in the middle like that's the one
i'm interested is that green m m in the
middle right
i'm not gonna like be able to dig
through and find that little green m
m the fastest way for me to do it is to
scoop up your entire bowl of m
ms and then sift it through a filter a
software program
right sift it through until my filter my
software program
pops up that green m m that i'm looking
for
like that's the most efficient way to do
it is to do
giant grabs i'm not really looking for
the red m m or the yellow m m i don't
care about the brown m
m like none of that really matters to me
i'm looking for this
one thing and the best way for me to get
it is to just
do a grab all and sift through it like
i'm not actually listening
like nobody's listening to all those
conversations think about like
millions of conversations there are not
people out there
just listening to conversations that's
not you know
literally like like i said before right
with cubicles like like office workers
is it you know is it some sort of like
ai that's basically
like scanning all of these phone calls
and text messages looking for keywords
or what is it so i so i i couldn't talk
about it even if i knew about it
but i will say that you know the
analysis is done by analysts
human beings right so data data
collection is done the way
any company would do data collection
right i mean it's just a different
a different style but like google
collects your data like apple collects
your data
tons of people collect your data it's
all done the same way right it's all
pulling
tons of data in the end it's a person
me or somebody else that's going through
that
individually you know eight and a half
hours every weekday
looking for connections looking for
information
you know there's there's not time like
we are very
focused right like we know who we want
and we know how to get there we are not
just idly
listening you know it's not like when
you flip through youtube and you're just
idly watching people it's not that
we have a job isn't it also true that we
haven't caught any terrorists
through the patriot act by by tapping
people's phone calls hmm
i do not know the answer to that
question okay and
and i will say that maybe you could
google it maybe find
some fake article some fake russian
article
i will say that i'm not i'm not a
terrorists caught through
the patriot act or tapping american
phone call something like that
yeah and i will say that i'm not
i'm not saying that something shouldn't
have been done about the patriot act
right the patriot act was something that
came out
of 9 11 for a specific purpose
and i think things like that often times
right because it was broad
so because it was broad and already in
use
it's easier to just kind of keep it
there yeah
so i'm not saying that shouldn't have
been reviewed because i think that you
know a policy particularly if a policy
comes out of like a time of war
that needs to be reviewed right like is
it still meeting the purpose
can we narrow it right so that's why i
say
you know i support whistleblowing right
i support
reviewing things that are already in
practice
because you know maybe something that
was okay
the first three years after 9 11 you
know
isn't okay 10 years down the road maybe
that's unnecessary maybe it's reaching
too far
maybe you do a review and you find out
that it's not serving its purpose you're
not actually
catching terrorists right i mean the
information
even if it wasn't carrying you know
capturing terrorists probably was good
for other
forms of intelligence that nobody's
talking about because nobody cares
um doesn't have as much of a like impact
when you talk about other forms of
intelligence
right but yeah i guess i mean the the
hard part to deal with is the fact that
they use something like 911
and the the clever marketing of calling
it the quote patriot act
to sort of pass it through with any
review right to push it through they
were trying to be so deceptive
and then i some guy got on the stand and
lied straight faced lied
about about doing this stuff yeah so
maybe i can understand
from that perspective why ed snowden
felt so strong about it
yes so that's why i think that's where i
think like like he had
his feelings right he had his feelings
about it
and then it had issues already right so
it wasn't like this
perfect magical thing that was working
and he blew it
like he had feelings about something
that was already
you know needed a review that could be
done
differently right that maybe needed to
change at this point in time
what i don't agree with was the way he
went about doing it
i feel like that just there
there would have been a better way i
think just blowing all the information
out and then running to
a hostile what you know a country that
is hostile to us intelligence i
don't think that that was the right way
and i think it hurt a lot of things i
think it
it possibly hurt more than it helped
right
i see what you're saying but if he would
have gone through the right avenues
if he would have gone through the right
chain of command
it might not have gone public and it
might not have hit all these news
stations and made the public aware of it
yeah
does the public need to be aware of it i
think so you think so
i think i think it can do it might do
it might do some harm up front but i
think long term
if i mean it's just like just like
with the cia or the government making it
public that they're aware of ufos or
extraterrestrial
extra terrestrial wow easy for you to
say
uh aircraft or whatever it's better if
the public is aware of it people are
looking for it people understand it
i feel like it is going to help
the nation or help the world understand
this thing
and i feel it's the same way with
something like this if something was
underhandedly
put in place to benefit something
even though it was not the right thing
to do sometimes just to
light a fire is the best way to
shine light on something and maybe if he
would have gone through the right chain
of commands there wouldn't have been
the public light shining on it to expose
it for its flaws and to expose the
government for all their flaws
right i mean i agree i agree that
you know a case-by-case basis
that public knowledge of certain things
has a benefit
but i also believe that there are lots
of things the public
doesn't need to know about like and the
problem with the way
snowden went about it was the fact that
it not only
revealed methodologies to the american
public it revealed methodologies
to all like the world so all these
other governments and intelligence
services
friendly or not suddenly knew something
we were doing
and that completely cuts off an avenue
of our ability to collect intelligence
like suddenly like we
are short information you know and that
gives them
a leg up and maybe it's something like
they had never even
thought about or considered doing maybe
it's something that they
because they have a dictatorship are
like
that's a great idea now we will do that
like we never thought about it before
but now
we all do the same thing where now
america can't do the same thing like
we've lost our edge and now somebody
else has gained an edge
so that's my issue with it like with you
know what what does the public really
need to know i don't know that they need
to know
a lot in fact
i